Narrator: In this shot from
"Central Intelligence,"
a man on a motorcycle does a backflip
and then knocks The Rock's character over.
But look behind the scenes
and you'll see nobody
was injured that day,
because this shot was
actually two separate takes.
This is a stunt trick
known as a camera lock-off.
And it's just one of many
tried-and-true techniques
Hollywood uses in films and TV shows,
making even the most
unimaginable stunts come to life.
In this scene in "Baby Driver,"
Ansel Elgort's character
pulls into a parking spot
and then runs out moments later.
In reality, that's a stunt
driver driving into the spot.
The driver's side gets
covered by this pillar,
which is also hiding Elgort.
So as Elgort runs out, it looks like
he's the one getting out of
the car in the first place.
This is a trick known as a Texas switch,
an in-camera effect in which
the actor and their double
will actually switch places
midway through the action.
The move involves close collaboration
between the stunt crew,
camera crew, and director.
Whether it's a whip
off of the actual actor
to something to come right back to them,
you can't just go focused on that person
and then put another person in.
Narrator: And the set needs
a natural hiding place
for the switch to occur,
like this rock that Sean
Connery is hiding behind
in "From Russia With Love."
The Texas switch isn't just for action.
It's even become a comedic staple,
in everything from "The Naked Gun"...
to "Scott Pilgrim vs. the World."
Knives Chau: Is Scott here?
Oh, you know what?
[glass shattering]
He just left.
Narrator: In this scene
in "Elf," for example,
Buddy needs to put a star
on top of a very tall Christmas tree.
First, Will Ferrell runs off camera.
Then the double runs out
and launches himself on top of the tree.
[tree crashing]
"Maleficent: Mistress of
Evil" contained many moments
where Angelina Jolie had to
perform dialogue in midair.
So how exactly did they make
it look like she was flying
while allowing for her to comfortably
and safely act in the scene?
They used this device,
called a tuning fork,
which consists of two
prongs that lock into
both sides of the performer's body.
The rig is controlled by a steering wheel
that is driven by stuntpeople
in blue or green suits
who are erased in postproduction.
Tuning forks were especially useful
for the shots where
Maleficent hovers in the air,
and the steering wheel makes
360-degree turns possible.
This was key for scenes
where the Fey twist
and turn in the air in "Maleficent,"
or when Mulan performs
full spins in the air
in the live-action remake.
You can also see it in
action in "Captain Marvel"
when Carol Danvers realizes
her full potential.
But the fork isn't a complete
replacement for wires,
which are still crucial for flight.
According to stunt
coordinator Monique Ganderton,
wirework helped give the
character more mobility
in "Captain Marvel" and "Endgame."
She had two wires on her hips only,
'cause I like them to have
freedom in their upper body.
And then a guy in a blue suit behind
just kind of puppeteer the leg up,
so her body could go side to side
and then come back up
into an upright position.
Narrator: In "Men in
Black: International,"
a menacing alien tosses
Agent H down a staircase.
To achieve this violent-looking motion,
filmmakers use a trick
called a ratchet pull.
During a ratchet pull, a performer is tied
to cables powered by an
air-pressure cylinder,
which pulls them either
backwards, forwards, or upwards.
The more pressure you use,
the farther they'll go.
In "Twilight: Eclipse," for example,
Monique Ganderton was
ratcheted 20 feet forward
after a CG wolf attacked her character.
Sometimes a simplified
version of a ratchet pull
called a dead man will do.
Instead of tying a performer
to a complex rigging system off camera,
the performer is tied to
a solid, stationary object in-frame.
Monique: What happens is,
when you fully commit,
you run, and you jump,
and you hit the end of that line,
and it just whips you
back onto the ground.
Narrator: You can see it performed
during the battle of
Wakanda in "Infinity War."
Monique: It gives for this violent,
this really simple but violent action.
Narrator: The dead man can also be used
to pull somebody off a horse,
like you see here in this cut
sequence from "Chaos Walking."
And when Thor gets hit
by Thanos in "Endgame,"
both a traditional ratchet pull
and a dead man were actually needed
so Chris Hemsworth's double,
Bobby Holland Hanton,
could be pulled forward and
then thrown to the ground.
Getting a stunt performer
to go through glass,
like in this scene from "The Hunt,"
requires a lot more force than
just a person's body weight.
When a character needs to
jump or fall out a window,
productions use tempered glass,
which shatters into tiny, harmless bits
instead of sharp shards.
But the glass itself is so strong
actors would simply bounce off it,
as you can see in this gag.
So in these moments,
the special effects team
rigs the glass with
explosives timed to go off
the exact moment the
performer falls through.
Daniel: By cracking it, you
weaken the whole system.
Narrator: In "The Hunt," the doubles
were attached to a wire
that pulled them backwards
just as the explosives go off.
Exploding glass also helped
hoist stuntman Daniel Hargrave
out a window in "The Accountant."
If you look on the ground,
you can see how tiny
the broken glass pieces actually are.
Stuntpeople are finding efficient ways
to update this trick too.
In "John Wick 2," the character
is thrown through a glass sculpture.
Daniel: Basically the
performers had to hit the glass
and let the computerized
system do its thing.
They put four charges that were
pressurized into the glass,
so it was on a pressure system.
As soon as that glass
pushed against the charger,
it had, like, maybe a eighth
of an inch of pressure on it,
so as soon as you'd push
through, it would blow.
[glass shattering]
Narrator: This risky stunk
from "Central Intelligence,"
in which The Rock's Bob
Stone is hit in the head
by a motorcycle, was made possible
by clever camerawork and visual effects.
In a trick known as a camera lock-off,
two actions are shot
separately from a camera
that is locked into the
exact same place both times.
Then those two shots are
combined using visual effects.
First, filmmakers shot a
motorcyclist doing a backflip.
Then, in another shot from the same angle,
stunt double Tanoai Reed was pulled back
on a ratchet to imitate impact.
The wires were erased and the
two shots layered together
into a seamless whole.
For moments like this,
stuntpeople can actually get hit by cars.
But lock-offs can lessen
the pain of vehicular hits.
Take this moment in "Atomic Blonde,"
where Gascoigne, played by Sam Hargrave,
is hit by a car and then smashed
into a van in front of him.
Daniel: Sam was on a ratchet,
so he ran to his mark, and we
ratcheted him into the van.
So no car hit him.
And then I was driving
the car, and we just,
same thing, lock-off, I
slid in as if I hit him,
and then they merged together.
And then he just turns, and
you see a wide shot of him
getting hit and flipped into this car.
[grunts]
Narrator: In "Underworld,"
the werewolf Lucian
has to run at superhuman speed.
And this isn't the work
of CGI or camera tricks.
It's actually a practical
effect called a magic carpet.
For this stunt, the crew will attach
a large tarp to a vehicle.
The performer will start
running on the smooth surface
as the car drives, allowing
them to run much faster
than a normal human would.
"Underworld" stunt coordinator Brad Martin
had actor Michael Sheen
and his stunt double
run on an 80-foot tarp attached to a car,
creating the appearance of
running at 35 miles per hour.
It was so successful that Martin
used it again in "Underworld: Awakening."
It can make just about
any type of character
look like they have superhuman speed.
Without a magic carpet,
the actors in 2001's "Planet of the Apes"
would never look as fast
as apes on all fours.
And it's also why Black
Panther looks so fast
when he runs and jumps
onto the back of a car
in "Captain America: Civil War."
However, this really only works
on flat surfaces like asphalt.
For off-road terrain, stunt crews may use
a weighted wire system
attached to a winch,
basically a giant spool,
to physically lift and propel them.
Look at the start of the battle of Wakanda
in "Avengers: Infinity War"
when Captain America sprints
past his fellow Avengers,
who are also running at full speed.
Stunt double Daniel Hargrave
was clipped into a harness
and attached to wires above his head.
The winch was then weighted
to counteract his body weight,
helping him move up and forward.
With the extra help, he could
run up to 24 miles per hour.
Daniel: I was about 50% on my feet,
so I still had to run and move
my feet as fast as possible,
but I wasn't actually doing
all the propelling myself.
Narrator: And it's helpful
with Marvel villains as well.
In "The Incredible Hulk,"
a similar weighted system
helped Emil outrun several soldiers
after taking the superserum,
launching actor Tim Roth to speeds
ranging from 30 to 40 miles per hour.
Some of Hollywood's most daring car stunts
need trained stunt drivers
to pull them off safely.
But what if you still
want to make it appear
as if the actor is the one driving?
A much more dynamic way to capture chases
is by using a Biscuit.
It's a vehicle that you
can put other vehicles on.
So while the actors appear
to be driving on camera,
the real work is being
done by a stunt driver
sitting in a driver's
pod just out of frame.
But because the stunt driver
isn't seen in a Biscuit rig,
the camera can capture
way more dynamic angles.
These rigs allowed the
audience to see Christian Bale
up close in "Ford v Ferrari,"
and some seemingly impossible
car moves in "Baby Driver."
In the movie "Drive," they
actually shot this part twice,
where Ryan Gosling's character
gets hit by another car.
First they shot the exteriors
with two actual stunt drivers,
then they shot Gosling on the Biscuit,
able to mimic every move to
get the inside of the car.
Director: And ready, and action.
Narrator: CGI can be used
to create big, safe fires.
But fire is still one
of the hardest elements
to create with visual effects.
It's easier to set a
real stuntperson ablaze.
So, how do they do it
without causing any harm?
Stunt performers often wear three layers
of fireproof underwear, which is soaked
in a flame-retardant
material called Zel Jel.
They then add on three
more layers: a rain suit,
a fire suit, and a thin cotton suit.
Even more Zel Jel will
go on any exposed skin.
According to "Game of
Thrones" stunt coordinator
Rowley Irlam, timing
is key for fire stunts.
A stunt performer can't be
fully engulfed in flames
for more than 15 seconds.
Crew: Fire!
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Out, out, out!
Narrator: And you often have to account
for multiple stunt actors.
Over 73 performers were set on fire
for the loot train attack
in "Game of Thrones."
Full fire burns also come
with acting challenges.
Performers need to hold their breath
while engulfed in flames
in order to not breathe
in any of the fire.
What stunt tricks do you
want to hear more about?
Let us know in the comments.
Monique: Daniel and I did a winch drop
that was almost 600 feet
together on "Hunger Games."
It wasn't a hard gag for us,
but it's like, if something
goes wrong, you die,
because it's, like, 600 feet.
But we had a great time.
We just, for three days,
we just went up, and down,
and up, and down. [laughing]